walking up the ramp walk into the
hallway I flashback to when I was a kid
and with the action figures inside
suddenly I had like a big lump in my
throat Ryan is doing many unexpected
things I think taking characters in new
directions individual stories of these
characters are elevated and made fresh
and new
that's what I love about Ryan's approach
to the story it's like a real journey of
discovery
ladies and gentlemen welcome to Episode
eight
first time shooting with mark the first
time Shane with Daisy
first time shooting a Star Wars movie
and we've got some cool stuff
[Applause]
sad like a dog whimper Brian's wonderful
personality is all over this film he has
flaws in other areas I just don't know
about
there's the weird thing that happens
when it's being built when you first
show up on it you're kind of over about
ropes by at all and then you get into
the nitty-gritty of working on it
ready
[Music]
naturally that level of it goes away and
you find yourself just focused on making
a scene work getting the shots and then
once in a while you're taking a little
break and sitting back and you look
around
to get the holy crap mountain again
concentrated work split up by holy craps
[Music]
hey everybody we got some new Star Wars
to break down whole bunch more Luke
Skywalker some better shots of Snoke
ship the supremacy so let's just go
through this shop by shot and even
though Star Wars tickets aren't on sale
right now I'm doing ticket giveaways for
like the other big movies that are
coming out so I'll just do that for Star
Wars - all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so a lot of the early behind the
scenes in this is stuff that we've seen
before it's just them building the
Falcon out they always have a standing
Falcon set on stage but sometimes
they'll modify it depending on the
scenes that they want to film or the
angles that they want to get so
presumably you just see different parts
of the Falcon than you saw during force
awakens like if you're going back to the
same place they always try to film it in
new and interesting ways but the
interesting thing is that you see r2d2
and c3po again in a falcon interior shot
so at some point during the movie
they're all going to come together even
though you know I don't really think
this is too much like Empire but in the
Empire style of moviemaking in trilogies
in the middle film the characters sort
of spread out further in the galaxy so
just remember that that's a big thread
in this film is that they're gonna be
splitting the teams and you see that in
some of this behind the scenes like you
see Finn and Rose in their resistance
outfits here this is probably as they're
on their way to Kanto bite the casino
planet when they're on their way to meet
Benicio Del Toro's character but then
right after that you see them in first
order gear looking like they're on some
infiltration mission this even looks a
little bit like Benicio del Toro but
it's a little too blurry to confirm that
but I think the idea is that at some
point they get caught and that's how he
winds up in his big standoff with phasma
that we saw in the last big trailer but
then in the background of this shot you
see Reis standing in what looks like a
scene with Poe's character so at some
point they meet back up either they're
caught maybe this is when they're on
Snoke ship this is the big wide shot of
that so this looks like the big chamber
scene that we keep seeing in that last
trailer where Snoke is having that
conversation with her about finding her
seeing the potential in her the
something special embrace your destiny
and they just totally lays the power of
the force on her so either somebody is
going to have to help her out in this
like Luke is gonna have to get his [ __ ]
together and help her out or it's going
to be some big triumph for her as she
overpowers him but I don't know that
work
right there yet even though we keep
talking about this in relation to the
narrative of the original trilogy in the
middle film Luke lost that fight to
Vader so I don't think that Rey however
powerful she might get is going to be
able to defeat Snoke in this movie
that'd be way too soon for something
like that but I'm not expecting her to
get her hand chopped off or anything
like that she might get maimed just a
little bit like when you lose a big
fight like this you usually lose a piece
of yourself either literally in the form
of a hand or you lose a piece of your
soul like you learn something very
damaging obi-wan never told you what
happened to your father so it'll be
funny to see if there's self-aware about
this at all like Luke is like this won't
go the way you think it's going to go
like Rey intends to try and confront
Snoke or maybe rescue someone and Luke
is just like wait a minute
we've already done this I tried this the
first time it did not go well I ended up
losing my hand when he takes Anakin's
lightsaber - you actually get an
up-close shot in a way that we haven't
before you can see right down the barrel
into the admit er in this cool to see
the accuracy of his mechanical hand
remember when it got blasted on Jabba's
Sail Barge when he went to rescue han
and Leia there's actually a score mark
here so if you're worried about them
paying attention to continuity they pay
attention to things on that level of
detail this is another Ock to set with
the Falcon it looks like they're filming
a lot of night shots there are a lot of
new shots of Carrie Fisher that look
really great it looks like she's giving
him some advice or telling him some
jokes there's a lot of stories from
behind the scenes of the original
trilogy with Harrison Ford and Carrie
Fisher just mercilessly teasing George
Lucas on said but the other really cool
thing here too is this cave scene that
Luke is in there's a couple different
shots and he's wearing a couple
different outfits during this footage so
he has his hermit gear here with this
leather outfit like they're putting the
leather glove on him here but he's in
his white Jedi robes when he's sitting
down inside this cave but I think part
of the idea is is that Rey will inspire
him just as much as she's inspired by
the great things that he's done in
history and then obviously you have the
new Rey gear here - she almost has three
different wardrobe changes there's the
first outfit when she gives the
lightsaber to Luke then there's a
slightly different robe then you have
her full-on Jedi Padawan gear even
though Luke Skywalker
the Jedi ordered to end that's kind of
what I'm thinking of Rey's costume here
like this is what she would be wearing
if she were a Jedi Padawan and it looks
very much like Anakin Skywalker like you
see him standing here next to obi-wan
obi-wan wears these very white robes
meant to visually tell you that he's a
very good person and it can where's very
dark colors just giving you an idea of
what's going on in its headspace how
conflicted he is so I think they're just
continuing that idea with Rey but it's
not necessarily confirmation of her
identity or where she came from the way
Rian Johnson talks about it in the film
they won't absolutely confirm anything
about her origins but they'll probably
be enough clues so that even though the
most casual Theory craftar will be able
to piece something together and then
obviously like the big reveal for
Episode nine but the only other really
cool shot it's not in this but they
released a new image is of Luke
Skywalker in the Jedi Library this is
presumably on Ock - I don't think
they've traveled to anywhere else these
creatures here are the guardians of the
temples they've been here since it was
created it's the original Jedi Temple
that's why Luke came here but it'll be
funny to see if they tried to literally
throw the book away on the force like
metaphorically Lucas like the Jedi Order
needs to die but that doesn't mean that
he wants to abandon the use of the force
they just they need to find some new
practices some new hidden knowledge so
they're metaphorically throwing the
books away on becoming a Jedi it would
be a shame if they literally did that
too because even if you're not gonna use
those books it'd be like throwing away a
holocron that's like a precious
commodity even if the information on it
is something that you don't need to know
or something you already know but let me
know in the comments what do you think
about all this I'm not expecting another
really big trailer until November but
once we get within the four week window
that's when you'll start seeing all the
promos and the trailers dropping the way
they're doing for thor ragnarok right
now so what will happen is as later this
week I have some more Marvel posting
I'll announce the ticket giveaway winner
for Star Wars when I post that while you
wait for everything click here to
rewatch all the Star Wars trailers and
you can click here for brand new flash
tonight thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight